[Musique]
paris ville immortelle ville lumière
berceau de l'histoire et havre des
poètes
paris capitale de la france dont tous
les étrangers disent qu'elle est unique
et dont nous sommes fiers
le charme de paris est indéfinissable
il vogue au fil des rues des monuments
et des méandres de la seine
pourtant le promeneur le touriste
l'amoureux de paris rencontre trop
souvent en certains endroits
une dame affreuse la saleté cette saleté
prend diverses formes elle s'insinue
partout comme le ver dans le fruit
aussi avons nous pensé que le journal de
paris pouvait peut-être apporter sa
contribution dans la lutte que mène ce
qu'ils veulent que paris soit souriant
propre et fleuri notre caméra s'est
promené un peu partout il y a tout de
même des choses que l'on ne devrait plus
voir en 1964 ces objets abandonnés sur
la voie publique n'offrent t-il pas
triste spectacle
si vous êtes allé en suisse en allemagne
au danemark ou en suède
avez vous vu chose pareille on a
l'impression quelquefois de vivre
moyen-âge et si paris n'est pas une
capitale aussi propres qu'elles
devraient l'être c'est de la faute des
parisiens pas tous il y en a fort
heureusement qu'ils aiment passer leur
ville pour la respecter
l'inconscience la passivité contribue
largement à compliquer la tâche de ceux
qui nettoient vous qui laisser votre
chien faire ses besoins où bon lui
semble
vous qui négligemment jeté votre paquet
de cigarettes n'importe où vous êtes
responsable vous direz il n'y a pas à
cette poubelle sont souvent pleines
peut-être mais les caniveaux sont là en
tout il mesure 13 100 km et ses images
en pour but de vous faire voir pourquoi
paris n'est pas aussi propre qu'il
devrait l'être les marchés sont aussi un
facteur de salissement les grilles
d'arbres à part cela avez-vous pensé que
tous les papiers toutes les ordures sont
souvent une source de maladies les
poussières les fumées sont déjà là il ne
faut donc pas ajouté
nous vous montrons aujourd'hui paris
sous un mauvais jour
un pari que vous n'aviez peut-être pas
remarqué les touristes les étrangers eux
le regarde avec des yeux neufs et
rentrer chez eux
faudra-t-il leur laisser dire paris
c'est magnifique mais les parisiens sont
sales aujourd'hui nous allons voir
comment paris fait toilettes une
toilette à la mesure de sa grandeur
à partir de 6 heures du matin le
ronronnement familier des bennes à
ordures ménagères se fait entendre
les poubelles sont vidées par 2420
éboueurs trois hommes par voiture pour
vous donner un ordre de grandeur
il y à 634 ben en service à paris mais
le ramassage est rendue de plus en plus
difficile par le nombre croissant
d'emballage moderne en papier en
plastique
le volume des ordures est en constante
augmentation alors que le poids varie -
les halles de paris fournissent à elles
seules 35 à 40 mille tonnes de gadoue de
détritus par an ce qui représente la
quantité d'ordures enlevé dans une ville
comme rennes par exemple en une année
ces ordures sont transportés à paris
bien sûr dans des usines d'incinération
à la périphérie de la capitale
elles sont pesées puis chaque benne
décharge son contenu automatiquement les
ordures sont ensuite brûlé 3600 tonnes
par jour en hiver de cette combustion au
tir de la vapeur destinés au chauffage
de certains immeubles en 1963 paris a
rejeté neuf cent trente mille tonnes
d'ordures parallèlement les balayeuses
entament leur balai à 4h30 du matin elle
arrose elle brosse elle lave tout à la
fois elles sont 94 à se partager la
tâche
aidés par les balayeuses ramasseuse pour
les caniveaux
lorsque ces derniers ne sont pas
occupées par les voitures bien entendu
une fois les ordures vie d enlever de
nombreux éboueurs deviennent balayeur
ils sont toute une armée à paris leur
rôle balayer les trottoirs bien sûr mais
aussi faire le coulage des caniveaux
ils sont d'ailleurs aidés dans leur
tâche par des balayeuses ramasseuse pour
trottoir à condition que les trottoirs
est au moins quatre mètres de large il y
a huit millions trois cent six mille
mètres carrés du trottoir à nettoyer
chaque jour à paris vous voyez que ce
n'est pas une petite affaire
aussi les services du nettoiement de la
ville de paris s'efforce de mécaniser au
maximum le nettoiement des grandes
artères paris propre c'est aussi la
sphère du centre d'action pour la
propreté de paris
c'est ce centre qui fait disparaître les
inscriptions les graffitis sur les
immeubles les monuments sur les plaques
des rues à l'aide de systèmes souvent
astucieux vous savez à présent pourquoi
et comment paris se salit vous avez vu
les moyens gigantesques mise en oeuvre
pour nettoyer les 13 100 km de trottoirs
et de rues
vous allez voir comment le centre
d'action pour la propreté de paris
oeuvre afin que notre capital soit la
plus jolie est la plus souriante
ce centre a son siège à l'hôtel de ville
et il est dirigé par pierre roger c'est
le préfet de la seine monsieur à ce
picard qui supervise le tout des
fourgonnettes du centre propreté de
paris partent chaque jour en croisade
soit pour enlever des graffitis sur les
murs soit pour décoller des affichettes
soit encore pour participer sur les
marchés à l'opération sacs
dès l'ouverture des marchés ses sacs de
80 litres de contenance sont mis à la
disposition des commerçants qui déposent
tous les détritus fibre papier etc
l'opération sac a déjà porté ses fruits
elle sera étendue mais les fourgonnettes
du centre ne sont pas seuls à partir en
croisade des enfants
promue chevalier la propreté sont les
gentils pionniers de l'opération paris
propre souriant et fleuri tenez regardez
les 1 action et méditer la leçon
autre problème délicat le pipi chiens
les caniveaux sont là les chevaliers de
la propreté aussi qui à force de
gentillesse et aidé par l'ingéniosité du
centre de la propreté de paris feront de
notre capitale un joyau si vous le
voulez bien nous allons récapituler avec
christian duval ex comment on peut être
un parisien digne de ce nom
[Musique]
m
nettoyer ces biens ne pas salir
c'est mieux mais on ne se rend pas votre
voiture dans le caniveau vous n'abîmez
pas vos pneus bien sûr vous favoriserez
les bonnes habitudes ici qui vous
faciliterez l'entretien de votre ville
barrie marie propre souriant et fleuri
[Musique]